Chinese leader Xi Jinping left Moscow
this morning wrapping up a closely
watched visit yesterday she and Russian
President Vladimir Putin held talks on
the war in Ukraine and an apparent swipe
at the West both Nations said it's
necessary to quote respect legitimate
security concerns of all countries Ramey
inocencio reports from Ukraine
choreographed pageantry for the world to
see Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin
issuing their joint statement on Ukraine
China remains impartial said she on the
side of peace and right side of History
China's plan could form a basis for
settlements at Putin but the west and
Kiev are not ready
that plan from February has been derided
by the West China has not demanded
Russia's military to withdraw in Moscow
she and Putin agreed an end to the war
should be settled through dialogue yet
gave neither a framework nor detail
after their state dinner she told Putin
they are driving changes not seen for
100 years but with no known decisive
deals on trade energy or Chinese weapons
China's leader was off
Washington says Putin has already blown
through resources in the past year
ammunition and missiles the tanks and
aircraft he's lost and absolutely the
soldiers that that he is literally
thrown into a meat grinder as the world
powers talked around Ukraine within the
war-torn country President Vladimir
zlinsky paid his respects to Fallen
Soldiers while ukrainians bear the brunt
of daily Russian shelling
we ask God to save the city for fewer
deaths says Lilia it's very scary
because people die every day just going
about their business
or after going to sleep three more
people lost their lives around the
capital region here in Kiev that's
because of fresh Russian strikes Gail
she said rainy dying every day just
going about your business that's tough
thank you very much reporting from
Ukraine